hi I'm Leah hi guys I'm Lucian hi I'm
cheating hi I'm Yuna and we're here at
BuzzFeed to play there or there yay
let's go
[Music]
make the cutest face you could possibly
make looking at that camera or
oh um no we refuse
cue the space one two three
[Music]
challenge another member to a thumb war
oh
but
I have long nails you have to be careful
dirty place
I suppose for a photo I think the Yuna
can do that put the muscle costume on
why me
Fried Chicken right now
so cool oh everyone eat a sour candy and
do the next dare sour candy we love sour
candy sour candy I love these
matcha
oh my God
that's the camera
I will do okay
take a Polaroid picture okay with a
picture because even if the stars
one two three
reveal the last photo in your camera
roll oh it's easy so we went to the park
and we took a groupie from a few minutes
ago swap shoes with another member swap
shoes
thank you oh
it's the new one and it's even not mine
thank you why oh
DM another celebrity right now we did in
the story we are only ornate about
though we don't have anything yeah no
friends so no DM
confess your love for your fans
I love you
oh it's too small
[Laughter]
[Music]
someone choose a topic and another
person will make a wrap and perform it
then Leah sing again
[Laughter]
then yeah
[Applause]
and then Julia with sour candy
sour candy sour candy sour sour sour
sour sour candy shop
wow it was a perfect wrap so your
favorite Tick Tock dance
I never be sad I don't know
if it never broke up
if you ever broke up I'll call you dead
I ever broke up
it's been around 10 times and walking us
straight oh so easy is he really good at
this yes in Korea we call it then I will
give you a hug yes are you ready I'm
ready you ready I'm ready okay go
eight seven eight eight nine go straight
yes cool straight
okay totally success juggle
for at least one rotation anyone good at
juggling I can't but I will try yes
easy peasy fuel with the toy ball
Blaster come on baby baby
foreign
[Music]
secret my tooth is broken
but I didn't go to the dentist so it's a
big secret to my parents
portray of another member okay
[Laughter]
make up a new synchronized dance
hmm
tomorrow
do an impression of another member yeji
like this marshmallow baseball one
person threw a marshmallow another
person hit it with a bat and a third
person tries to catch it in their mouth
yet you should catch it with your mouth
Yes Yes catching it with your mouth oh
smells so good
I think you should come a little bit
more here and like lower your position
and like open your mouth
you ready yes I'm ready
oh I'm sorry
great
show us a hidden talent hidden talent
it's not hidden what's yours
Korean traditional instruments
very similar yes
success single highest
on another member's arm with a marker
okay cute harmonized harmonize
foreign
pick another member up off the ground
for three seconds
the stirring contest three two one
why are you
[Music]
fit as many marshmallows in your mouth
as you can oh my God
you have to like push it in like they do
it at the dentist you know
I think Yuna in Tara
hurry up
[Music]
wait I want to take a picture
yeah
we succeed
I think we were pretty fast yeah maybe a
record do you have Yankee
well thank you BuzzFeed thank you so
much for having us I hope you guys
enjoyed it
[Music]
bye